after september's general election the
german conservative party was left
reeling losing its voters to the social
democrats and kingmaker parties the free
liberals and the greens
now as the conservatives seek to
redefine themselves women in the party
want better representation and young
people are calling for more of a say
here in the headquarters of the german
conservative party behind the apparent
calm a tremor can still be felt
after 16 years in power chancellor
angela america's party recorded its
worst ever election results in
september's general election
and despite coming second behind the
social democrats the cdu walks a thin
line it needs to regain its voters
confidence amin lachet the chancellor
candidate has hinted at stepping down as
party leader after a campaign marred by
faux pain gaffes looking ahead younger
conservatives want to use this setback
as an opportunity to renew their party
to begin with some want to see more
gender parity
[Applause]
we simply have too few women in the
party that is our job first of all to
provide more for more women and then
also of course to ensure these women are
visible and become visible
more women and also more space for
generational change even seasoned
conservatives are making way for younger
parliamentarians
defense minister ana gretchen karenbauer
and economy minister peter altmaier
recently renounced their bundestag
mandates to set the pace
i think it's about achieving
generational change in the cdu
and i think peter
and annie
have sent a great signal to make it
possible
when we are in the opposition if we go
into opposition it will of course be
very important that we renew ourselves
for the next federal election and also
that generational change takes place
but i also want to emphasize that it's
not just about lining up younger people
rather that we need a good mix both in
the party and in the parliamentary
groups
speaking about generational change we've
asked younger voters what they think the
conservatives should do next
the youth are more oriented to the
greens and the conservatives so you have
to look at their motivations what
reasons they have to prefer this party
we'll have to see if the old timers
really want to give up their power
mankind
it's hard to see a change taking place
or it's not yet quite clear that change
is happening at all
with a chance of playing a part in the
next government lessening by the day
there will be a lot of soul-searching
among german conservatives
if they do indeed go into a position